Oh,
Yay.
Coffee on a Tuesday in block 15.
Hello to everybody who is new speaking
for the 500 who were here before and
myself.
Welcome to or generosity during the
project for awesome.
Expanded my conception of what could be
done in this community.
And though it's not enough,
clearly I can only say thank you.
Oh,
window.
Okay,
so now that that's done,
I think the president wanted to say
something.
My fellow Americans major combat
operations in Iraq.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
No,
no,
not that bright.
So as your commander in chief on behalf
of a grateful nation,
I'm proud to finally say these two words
and I know your family's agree.
Welcome home.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
The Warner rack is over December 15th,
2011,
eight years and 270 days later,
but he's early as 2004.
I think the worse thing about a smart to
most as deliberately putting your hand
on a sizzling pam,
we have to be careful about simplifying
a complex decade because it will be left
to us nine years later to appraise this,
tell a story in a way which is loyal to
the truth,
but also answerable to the 4,000,
487 troops who gave their lives to it
and the many more thousands who gave
their arms or their legs or their
ability to use either,
but that I am not going to talk about
the war proper.
What I want to talk about is what
happens when you burn your fingers on a
sizzling pan.
If it's happened to you,
then you know that if it's a good solid
burn that some of your skin is gonna.
Stay on that path and his troops.
Levi records a bit of our collective
skin which will stay in that country for
some time or roughly 16,000
Americans still in Iraq to aid with the
ongoing diplomatic effort there and
effort which is primarily aimed at
making sure we secure and alliance with
the young democratic government.
We worked so hard and spent so much to
put in place is particularly important
because it sits on the largest oil
reserves in the world according to new
seismic data and with so much
uncertainty in the region because of the
Arab spring.
Iraq remains a very strategic allies,
so the $16,000
split up like this.
2,000
diplomats and 14,000
civilian contractors are.
Those contractors are there for general
light support.
Everything from transportation to food
service at mess hall and the other half
are security contractors.
I want to talk about the ladder security
contractors because you hear that term
tossed around a lot,
but I think a lot of people don't really
know what it means.
I did the official name for the entity
is private military company or PMC
though many know them as security
contractors or even mercenary,
so they don't really like that last.
Maybe,
maybe you
can see what whatever you want to call
them.
They are corporations that deal in the
peripheral duties of war for profit.
They can't engage in offensive
operations according to the Geneva
Convention that they can do almost
everything but including defensive
operations with a liberal use of the
term defense.
They build planes,
maintain them,
even fly them in conflict zones.
They supply bodyguards for diplomatic
construct,
bass military camps,
operate intelligence systems,
supply weapons and ammunition,
and they trained soldiers.
In fact,
most security contractors are retired
soldiers,
men and women who come out of combat
with a set of skills applicable nowhere
else,
but income that contract companies will
pay them generously for those skills,
often more than double what the army
pay.
It's no skin off their back because the
private military industry has boomed in
the last 10 years,
really ever since 1991.
When the Pentagon led,
by then defense secretary,
Dick Cheney paid a company called Brown
and Root Services eight point
$5,000,000,000
to study the use of private military
forces with soldiers in combat zone.
Now,
brandon and services was a subsidiary of
Halliburton oil company where Cheney
served as ceo between his time as
defense secretary and vice president.
He's studied film that outsourcing
duties to private military companies was
cheap,
so after nine slash 11 when the Bush
administration announced its war on
terror,
the role of pmcs was increased
dramatically during combat operations in
Iraq.
Tens of thousands of security contractor
supplied necessary goods and services to
the troops as they toppled Saddam's
regime.
And when the invasion ended and the
occupation began,
contractors only grew in number.
The government was outsourcing its
responsibilities to the point of
confusion.
April 2004 for contractors from a
company called Blackwater were killed,
burned,
and dragged through the streets of
Fallujah and central Iran.
This footage was released to the news
outlets and it prompted a revenge
mission to recapture the city Operation
Vigilante resolved in which 27 Americans
were killed.
One hundred 80 and surgeons and 600
Iraqi civilians,
you see security contractors don't have
access to all the tactical information
that the troops have,
yet still,
they carry guns and operate within all
the same theaters of conflict.
They don't fall into the chain of
command so they can leave anytime they
want to get multimillion dollar
contracts with the State Department,
but being private companies,
they don't have to provide itemized
records of where the money is going.
Perhaps the most troubling thing of all
about plcs is that they don't fall under
the uniform code of military justice.
That lack of accountability,
that lack of oversight,
which alarms many,
the questionable deaths of dozens of
Iraqis which will never be prosecuted as
the war ends.
The contractors will stay indefinitely
to provide security for the embassy in
Baghdad,
Iraq and Bosnia.
The last being a city 20 miles from the
border of Iran and sitting on one of the
largest oil fields in the world.
Yes,
oil,
sexy,
delicious,
scrumptious.
If I ran seizes,
control of it in one way or another
weekend,
see gas prices rise to five,
six,
seven,
$10.
Again,
I think it's fair to say that the only
reason we went to Iraq was for the oil,
but there's no doubt that in large part
and with the help of pmcs it's why we're
staying.
No.
Hello everybody and welcome to the
special ed message.
I got some news.
I'm going to be on the last word with
Lawrence O'donnell on Msnbc Thursday
night this Thursday,
December 22nd at 10:00
PM eastern time.
So if you want to check it out,
I'm gonna be talking about the kind fund
and project for awesome and the project
for awesome video.
What I need you to do is storm John
Green and hank green so that they know
that this is happening so that I can
know that we still have time to donate
because I think this could provide a
nice big push to the project for
awesome.
Uh,
and,
and that's it.
So thank you very much for watching the
video and I will see you later.